fue el último día de servicio en la
jackson we mens health organization la
única clínica que ofrecía a las mujeres
del estado de misisipí la posibilidad de
abortar o de
postergar en el caso
de las mujeres que decidieron poner fin
a su embarazo fueron como siempre
presionadas a las afueras de la
institución tuvieron que entrar
exportadas pero para estos activistas la
misión no termina con el cierre de la
clínica
lo que el futuro parece para nosotros
porque la fábrica de abortos está
cerrando sigue siendo lo mismo
seguiremos yendo a predicar el evangelio
en las calles como lo manda dios y por
lo tanto esto es sólo una de las muchas
cosas como cristianos a las que nos
oponemos y clamamos a la pérdida al
arrepentimiento
misisipí es uno de los estados más
conservadores de eeuu una clínica se
convirtió en epicentro de una guerra
ideológica
y
estos zapatos son biblias pegadas con
cinta adhesiva empieza yo solo intento
supongo hacer una declaración de que no
me importan sus razones para lo que
están haciendo con respecto a las
razones por la que están aquí nada de
esto tiene sentido para mí y siento que
este es un mensaje muy claro
el 24 de julio la corte suprema derogó
el fallo del tows versus wave que
permitía el acceso al aborto a nivel
federal y misisipí es uno de los tres
estados que tenía lista desde el 2007
una de las llamadas leyes gatillo es
decir con la derogación de raw entran en
vigor nuevas restricciones aquí el
aborto quedará prácticamente prohibido a
excepción de los casos de violación y
cuando corre peligro la vida de la madre
y la jackson we mens health organization
cerrará sus puertas un destino que
podrían pronto compartir muchas otras
clínicas en eeuu